I'm talking to mr.
Lynn irvine who worked on the sydney
harbour bridge on the approach is do you
remember getting the job. Do you miss
trevor and i remember i remember getting
a job but i don't remember the dates of
getting the job you know i worked there in
three different periods each period
possibly as near as i can remember
of three months. And of course i
did see we had or rather these
people friends that i knew that got
me the job. They they this was their
sort of trade. And me being out of
work they pushed me in and i did
a job laboring what job exactly did you
do on the approaches we did the asphalt
thing on the concrete
arches. There was i think
two or three layers of of asphalt on the
concrete. And then of course they put
bricks over the top to protect the asphalt
and then they filled it in with rob
on all kinds of filling and tied it so that
was actually the waterproofing for the
for the arches of the artist yes.
Waterproofing. Was it hard work or it was very
hard and of course spend. I was only.
I was only twenty one there as i
can remember twenty one years of age. Two
member exactly what they work in teld
what you had to have to do. Yes i. It
was my job to get the boilers or the
house phone. Tubs ready for when the other
men came in and i used to have to leave
home or 3:00 3:30 in the morning.
I lived in red from that time and
i left home and have to walk right up to
the bridge approaches from red front which
was quite all every morning and
i had to light the fires wood
fires underneath the boilers. Put
the blocks of asphalt in the
tubs. And melt it. Ready
for them coming at 7:30.
They started it was really ready. But
it was near enough when they came and
it was
a matter of stirring it with big steel
paddles metal paddles and breaking it up
till it was ready he used up stoke
the fire as well. Yes i had to stoke
a fire as well. Yes i know how many of you
how many of these asphalt machines were
there for the southern side you were
on the southern side. Yes i was on the
southern side all the time. Actually there
weren't machines they were just these as
i said these tubs boilers and we
used to have three normally and
how many of you for them. Well. Well they
used to help when they came on i used to
start it off get all the fires going
and get one near enough to ready for
action and when they came in. Normally
they they marked it and sort of
helped me
a bit. And then when they were ready for
work and the stuff was ready to lay.
Sometimes or more often than not. There
was another man to help me carry the
buckets. It was it was ladled into buckets
and carried and lower down lower down
out for them to get at the bottom and come
up with it. Putting it on the concrete
and what did they do painted on a
porter now. Now they used a trowel
a wooden wooden sort of float
to put it down with with wood.
And they could work it and spread
it on to about i think that's how i
think it finished up about an inch or inch
to court. I think took out two or three
coats
a notch or so you were responsible for
melting down and keeping molten all
the asphalt for the southern approaches.
It's right yes yes i was and did you do
the whole of the southern approaches.
Yes yes. Well it's amazing
that there was another lot on the north
side. Well i don't know the north side
didn't have any similar effort
at the. That we did the
north side didn't have any of these arches
anyway. You see what it did but probably
they weren't working at the same time as
you. Did they have well if you think about
it. There's the fitzroy street out there
is the orchestrators that's eleven the
street are never taken much notice over
there so of course i didn't know now. Yes
well they must have been
a separate contract altogether. Yes well
i didn't i wasn't aware that there was
much done on the south
side so you see there's
a you never can tell what's going on around
the place i know that if you look on
the other side there's
a terrific amount of arches there's
also the arches where the shops are and
wilson's point station. I never thought
about that and then there's the police
station the bridge police station which is
on the north side underneath the row was
the row with it yes but that was in the
pile or not and it used to be on the
demo the police station is actually in one
of the arches on the on the north side
anyway. No i didn't realise that there was
so much in this i said but you learn all
the time and it was amazing that there was
just you with three of these melters the
whole lot you can you remember how long you
worked there. Well as i say no i can't
it's it's it's
a bit hazy times and you see i
think possibly three months
each period. Possibly a bit more.
I don't know and we did you have
a job in between terms of not well little
little bits and pieces of jobs you see we
did we did little bits and
pieces we did a bit of
a job on the top of wrigley's
spearmint factory. In between times
we did another job at
a cafe in town and i can't remember
which cafe. Do you remember the firm
that was doing the subcontract that you
worked for well the it was the business and
private was that that took the contract
that had the contract sublet you see
. Other than that i i don't know there was
a jack mitchell that worked with us. They
were all together about maybe five or
six of us. There were six and yourself
six laying the asphalt as near as i
yes. So look a lot of work
to do a lot of it was
a very very hard work very hard to they had
to let the brick work to know. No doubt
that again i'm not sure i think
that. I think that was a
t partment of main roads it could have
been i'm not too sure when it was there is
a public works department but who did what
and exactly how much nowadays i don't
know but apparently did the people who had
the contract do any of the voting for
for the city railway. No because the st
james and museum station were done in
exactly the same way they were
all laid concrete then they put
a spell then brick on top. Yes well
as the fellows that i worked with
didn't do any of that i think that was
before. Wasn't it before the bridge.
Yes. Well now i don't know about that
because i met these fellows in tarry
that was where i met him i
was working in tari for
a builder and it wasn't very good up there
but then again i didn't want the little
country town you know how you know when
you're young. I want to do big city life
and of course i packed up and
went to sydney which was
a big mistake. Really why did you feel
that was work harder in sydney. No oh no i
just i couldn't get the work i was in and
out of work and i was more out of work
than in work harder to get and all of much
harder to get more competition down easy
. Do you remember any more of the gangs
that they're working with he was just the
six and yourself other than you
that at all. How are of our lot.
Did you have anything to do with the concrete
as before. Who were public works. No
other and passing time of the
day i used to. I watched them
while we were on one of the archers. I
watched them put the shuttering timber and
the reinforcing for the next arch.
. And i well remember one man i'm not sure
if that was on the last arch that was
the highest one man got on the he
climbed up to the top and he was just
petrified with fear and they had
a job to get him down he just clung and
they couldn't get him away. Did you do the
. Over the eye go cut when they were
in that as well that you know. No.
Unless you see unlet it was part of the
three arches to the approach as oh yes it
was one of the three arches is that are
they. Well in we did i can't remember now
you see it
a little bit hazy and. I've been
around the argyle since. But i
haven't taken much notice when he said
they blasted down the old arch ring which
was kids turn and then they built
a new one over the top because it had to
be an awful lot of wider and stronger. Yes
. Well then we must have work time on because
i know we worked on the first second
and third archers. And i worked with all
the time with the same to provos i've
since tried to locate them but the
no name in the phone book and
while they might be dead now because they
were about roughly seven years older than
me which would put them to eighty. Where
did they come from they came from
birmingham the two brothers and the the
other one the jack mitchell he came from
london. They were came from london
one. I can't remember his name
to me anything else about the work that
you member the working conditions. Well
working conditions our conditions
were pretty primitive we didn't have
any. Place to sit for lunch. We had to
sit outside. And if it did rain then
we were just too bad we got wet. We
had no inside canteen or anything
as such we sat night our sandwiches there
on the site. So working conditions
just didn't exist. And toilet.
No we didn't have any
toilet facilities at
all. You'd have to find
a public toilet. Where we just had
to do the best we could. There's
a long long wait. Of public toilets from
where we were. What sort of money did you
get paid. Remember again roughly i'm not
too sure. I would say that when i did get
up for a week possibly
round about six pounds
a week that was good money then was there
was good money but is i said it was very
very hard and hot work and what time to
do you started at sort of 3:00 in the
morning i was supposed to start at five
o'clock in the morning to get the fires
ready and i was away from home at 3:30 in
the morning from red fun because i had to
get right down to the city through the
city right up to the approaches which was
quite
a walk. And of course i probably it took
me all more than an hour. I would say it's
true that no trams. No i don't think there
were trams many case i couldn't afford
them. I didn't have much money.
No days. Yes it's hard but
the money when you got it was good but
you didn't you said when you did get
a full week did that mean
that you very seldom got
a full week. Well no we did get
for a week just sometimes we have
a part possibly rained off. You know
with the weather. But when i did get
a full week which i suppose was
a reasonably regular i got
six pounds sometimes seven
a dependent what i was doing is here and
of course in that time i had to pay back
a little bit of the money to the my
landlady for digs that i hadn't been
able to pay you know i'll have a lot.
She good like that of a good woman
a very good very nice people.
Carl was their name. I
haven't been able to locate any of the
family there either because i lived with
some five years and so i really
got to know them whenever
you were out of work and couldn't pay they
used to worry me they didn't want to me
they they actually have to do
it. When i could when i did get
a bit of work. I gave them most of my
money. I never spent much on myself.
I didn't think i couldn't
afford to then i did smoke.
I didn't buy much by way of clothing. I
could still i couldn't afford that so
that was it. One more thing before we
go for the work and the things. Do you
remember what time you finished work. Oh
yes. I usually finish around five o'clock
at night so that was
a twelve hour day for you. It was oh yes
twelve hours plus. It used to have to
watch them well they say well they're cool
turn as well. The. No no. What we did
you see when the cool down. We used to have
to clean them out the boilers and then
once a week as they emptied
we had to they had a they had
a detachable bottom inside
that we used to knock out with
a fourteen pound hammer. You see by the
end of the week inside of the pot. It was
built up with layers of hard hard rock hard
asphalt you see. And we used to have to
smash the bottom out with
a fourteen pound hammer and then
clean the rock asphalt off the
sides you see clean them and set them up
again for monday morning. That was always
on a saturday afternoon or on
a friday afternoon saturday
morning we did that. We you were
a union member. While you're working on the
bridge. No i didn't know what union was
i never. I think i'm not sure i think i
joined the union once in the world as union
but was that the b.w.
Were you i think it was i don't
think i couldn't i couldn't have
a panic subscriptions anyway and ever i
never had much money to do this when you
see. And of course unions in nose days who
were there are strong as they are now.
And yes there was
a preference for union this enforced on
the bridge. Oh yes yes but as i said
before trade unionism
wasn't strong and we were
never in the union. I know that i think
you are going back to depression times
before they got you've got the job you were
from england originally how did you get
to australia. Well week i came
out under the the. Tread not
boys scheme. It was an immigration scheme
for bringing boys from england. I was
eighteen just just turned
eighteen. And we sailed
on the bendigo yes as bendigo
from tilbury docks. I think the
twenty eight 27th or 28th of april 1927.